what we've read the GOP memo alleging
surveillance abuses by the DOJ and FBI
investigating the Trump campaign well
the president also Declassified the
Democratic rebuttal
we are awaiting a decision from the
White House the president has seen the
memo he met with Deputy Attorney General
rod Rosen Stein within the last hour to
discuss some of the differences between
the two memos and we are undergoing the
exact same process that we did with the
previous memo in which it will go
through a full and thorough legal and
national security review we're in the
middle of that process when that's
completed the president will be given a
thorough briefing on the findings of the
different organizations and stakeholders
that are involved and will make a
determination at that time Democrats say
they want it released as quickly as
possible but they're also voicing some
concerns what I'm more concerned about
Allison is that they make political
redactions that is not redactions to
protect sources or methods which we've
asked the Department of Justice and FBI
to do but redactions to remove
information they think is unfavorable to
the president that could be a real
problem and and that's our main concern
at this point but it will certainly
appear that the White House is trying to
stonewall again if in fact they make
these political redactions that we fear
there is a theory it could be a trap for
the president a source tells Fox News
the rebuttal is filled with sensitive
details intentionally to pressure the
White House to either block it or
significantly reduct it so I guess that
is a ploy that someone could use
Kimberly if they if they wanted to make
a big deal out of it of course right
it's it's like made-for-tv moment if he
redox anything oh the least transparent
president and the country's ever seen
Adam Schiff will run to the podium will
probably like pull a leg muscle trying
to get there in time to be like look at
this and like show it all redacted so
it's a made-for-tv moment and that's
what they're hoping for to say listen
it's so bad and damaging look at the
president wants to keep all of this out
and keep it from the American people he
wants to only wants to release what's
favorable to him he did this as an
attempt to distract that's the argument
of what they'll say so there is a little
bit of you know a rich
skinned it but you can't release one
really and not release the other the
Democrats really thought one that the
Republican memo was a flop so they
basically said and Judge Napolitano said
they over-promised and under-delivered
do the Democrats risk the same oh yes if
they don't if they're unable to make the
case the problem here is and I think
Kimberly actually said it should be
released in the name of transparency
which was the argument last week about
releasing the Devin Nunez memo the only
problem there was of course that there
was so much classified information not
attached and so it's hard to fully gauge
whether or not they're making a serious
case or it's just about discrediting the
FBI the Department of Justice and
undermining the mulher investigation in
this case you also have questions about
classified information that's attached
and the issue for me is once you agree
to let out the Republican memo how can
you not let out the Democrats response
and the only issue here it seems is
whether or not President Trump feeling
that he's being intentionally lured into
a trap decides no I'm not gonna do it
and doesn't give a hoot about what
anybody has to say even though he's the
one by the way who put on the dog and
pony show started this well if my sense
jesse is that the White House will
release it as long as it doesn't
compromise sources and methods and maybe
if there is some sort of a trap in there
they might try to go back to the
Democrats and say you need to fix this
but my sense is they're going to release
it what do you think they will the
Democrats are running scared they're
afraid of the truth they know the truth
not on their side and ynyn well they're
scared of this far as a memo that came
out last week they're saying it's not a
big deal because they know it's a big
deal because they can't address the
facts on the merit I don't trust Schiff
he's a proven liar and a leaker remember
he leaks the Don Jr testimony they blow
up in his face when he got the date
wrong and then he said this Nunez memo
was going to jeopardize national
security it was going to compromise
methods and it was going to be tampered
with all of those things were not true
so he's trying to trap the president
into redacting something to make him
look like an obstruct you knows what the
president's going to do he's going to
side on the side of national security
they
they have to play games because they
can't address the abuse that they
undertook at their own Justice
Department and FBI now the real
collusion is with Hillary and the
Russians she was one that paid for an
agent to go to Russia she was the one
that paid for fake Russian dirt and she
was the one that paid for the wiretap on
the Trump campaign call me better lawyer
up because Comey knew that it was
unverified and salacious Comey testified
to the Senate that it was unfair fide
and salacious
yet he was the one that brought this
unverified and salacious document to the
FISA judge that is against the law you
cannot present unverified information to
a FISA judge says he's in big trouble
also why did he deliver this unverified
document to president-elect Trump when
he knew Hillary paid for it
but didn't tell the president-elect that
Hillary paid for it and then the day
after he briefed the President on the
dossier it leaks very suspicious he
should maybe stop writing his book and
lawyer up you know if I was a judge I'd
say excuse me lawyer counselor there was
no relevance to anything you said to
this case yeah what's a one thing that I
said it was incorrect I think you said
that be one thing because Steele's
dossier may have been paid for by the
Clinton campaign it should have been
ignored so if the information was
verified so we don't take unverified
information to apologize you don't know
that it's unverified we'd homie said it
was unverified did you hear that he said
he hold the tape he said he called he's
checking they're a bunch of criminals is
that right and what is on the dossier
that has been verified one because our
own brain room says they were not
so are you gonna go against your own
company on me it's me even commands but
I must say you're out there buddy you're
just trying to cover it up oh sure he's
helping right to lead radius oh yeah
there's a giant Donald Trump looming
over your shoulder this is who's gonna
help heal this show it's gonna take a
lot okay I like to back the New York
Times effort to release the transcripts
of the petitions put in front of the
FISA Court and we'll know once and for
all for the first time since this Court
was created in 1978 wood really went on
in order to win over that Judge and I
had to refresh my memory on this because
it's always around terror cases up until
President Trump was elected that and as
you know Kimberly the judge sits here by
himself there's no counter argument or
defense attorney they just go FBI says
could you take a look at this I'd like a
warrant and there's no push milord
right than not but but it should be
blatantly I like a warrant and they said
okay well we'll take a look at this and
you know what judging by everything I
see here at a thirty-five thousand times
I'm only going to reject 12 this won't
be one of the 12 so it's rubber-stamp
des put forward so there's two things
it's going to be a very very interesting
to find out in this 10 page memo number
one they say they're going to put in
context Andrew McCabe statement when he
came out and said we would not have
gotten as far as a warrant without the
dossier they says take it out of context
but the quotes accurate so I can't wait
to see how they put that in context I
guess was through laughter or something
I'm not sure the second thing is the
footnote at the bottom of the page they
said it was a political organization
that paid for the dossier where it
didn't say Hillary for America or a
Democratic National Committee or
anything we know that would have been a
blatant way to say who pay for the
dossier that might have changed the
judges mind didn't ask
we don't know because we don't have the
transcripts and that's what we need to
see it if I'm a judge the follow-up
question would be by the way well what's
the name of this organization that gave
you this dossier what does it matter it
is very similar one if you're coming at
me and I'm saying why is this guy mad at
me well it turns out my enemy is scream
and telling you bad things about me
before I got here that means you dis
you're dispossessed to hate me
so this people were paid the dossier had
a political motive to what they call
facts the political motive is get
Hillary elected the person that God had
said I will do whatever I can to make
sure Donald Trump is not elected there's
nothing I said that was inaccurate there
so let's see the argument let's see the
transcript well the first thing I would
say to you is one they were FISA
requests on Carter patient way before
dime 2013 one point incident notice
professor than what you hang on slow
down and then subsequent they were
requests and again they had to be
approved especially in the last case as
we know by rod Rosenstein who is a Trump
I'll accept your argument in why you
need the dossier what are you the
dossier because you need the dossier
what all five times you need this
dossier five times if the dossier
doesn't exist until late 2016 no not yet
to get to flourishing following but you
turn around approved for another time
you have to prove that there is still a
need to be following additional evidence
to that and I'm not necessarily for one
thinking that we need to open up all
this is just a to me a slippery slope to
to open up all of law enforcement to
crowdsourcing by people like us like I'm
not qualified yeah because it undermines
their ability because it doesn't involve
us who's involved me if I'm you know if
I'm Carter I'd like everything I can I'm
the most important person in the world
if I'm if I'm someone surveilling me
because of a petition putting for the
FISA Court I'd like to find out the true
page here he is from this morning take a
look these are your words I've served as
an informal advisor to the staff the
color you're advising the Kremlin they
would say a lot of people advising a we
were part of an informal group you know
and meeting in Geneva Paris
got a meeting in the new york stock
exchange the first meeting was in the
new york stock exchange what I've seen
that far is just complete ridiculousness
you've been under surveillance from the
court have been since October 2016 since
that time have you ever spoken to Donald
Trump I didn't never spoke with him
since I never spoke with him anytime in
my life you've never spoken to Donald
Trump in your life hell no email no
texts nothing like that never
he's never even talked to the president
yet he threw the election for Trump yeah
how did he get the sharpest knife in the
drawer but I will say this they just
released some documents from 2015 from
the Justice Department that said Carter
page actually helped the FBI put away a
Russian spies exposed them that we're
infiltrating our systems in the United
States so either he's a double agent
which he's not clearly might be because
he's you know he's that smart to play
both sides or why would the Russians
recruit him again after he helped put
Russian spies away a few years ago and
he's an informal unpaid adviser the
Trump campaign it just doesn't add up
why you'd open up an investigation it's
so clear that Papadopoulos and he threw
the election for Trump why can't you see
that it's so obvious a guy he'd never
talked to or texted before through the
election and stopped Hillary Clinton for
the first dozen texts yes thank God